I gotta say I'm loving the blonde hair I
really love it yeah you what do you
think you're you having more fun as a
blonde or less fun well IIIi don't know
I've being blonde you know it depends if
you're blonde enough to have fun I'm
always having fun are you gonna keep
this for a while well let's see I want
to keep letting it grow you know I don't
know if I'm gonna handle it because
having long hair is just kind of
difficult yeah I don't know how women do
it super difficult but but yeah for now
I'm handily okay I'm good all right
Latin AMAs congratulations you're eating
a big award on Thursday the the
extraordinary revolutionary award now
what does that mean to you to hear that
that you're a revolutionary well that's
that's what I always wanted to win my
career you know doing different things I
think that that's very important for me
to Donna is gonna be beautiful for me
because I've been like waiting for that
mom and you know it so to somebody and
know one of the things that I'm doing
for my career for the young people and
the thing that that's gonna be an
incredible award that is gonna remind me
that work hard in knees on face off yeah
absolutely and you get to perform which
is always fun I know you're hit the
stage with your boy Prince voice my boy
right you guys are so excited aren't you
yeah yeah I love him he became like
almost like a brother to me so so yeah
we always having fun and when we have
these kind of events awards actually
he's coming with me to my concert he's
gonna join the concert in meta-gene and
Bogota he's coming because he's my
brother here he's part of my family
already we have this song together so
yeah we always having fun you know I
asked him because the ladies want to
know I said which one of you is gonna
take your shirts off first on the stage
on Thursday he's gonna do it he's gonna
do it I always I always doing my concert
and I'm not in my concerts toys
Roy's touring you know yeah he's behind
the gym together away
yeah actually actually we did it we did
it before yeah but he's weak okay he's
like around the corner he's ready to
come out yet I love you know you're
strong you got it he's not even good all
right so
for the first time ever they have all
female hosts for the show I mean you
know Latin music is pretty
male-dominated how does it feel to know
that women are finally getting that
recognition that they deserve I love it
yeah yeah I really love that you know
that I've been oh I'm always said that
before like men without women were
nothing so thanks for being here thanks
for doing it I know it's a huge step for
for women to to do this so I really
appreciate it I know what like you're
gonna see something very important in my
my show my performance I'm gonna be
surrounded of a woman but you're gonna
see you're gonna love I have a big
surprise for you and it's like showing
the the girl power that's yeah that's
what I want to do in this in this
performance amazing maluma I mean do you
have any favorite female urban singers
right now like when you're hitting the
gym and we know you do could we see your
Instagram you know are you listening to
any female singers on your playlist yeah
I love Becky gee I love Kyle G I love
nothing attached I love Anita she's like
my sister too so yeah and and I've been
working with Kyle G in the past two days
so I love her - I know I know that
there's a lot of telling them and in the
women industry so that's that's very
nice I'm a huge fan of the the female
music I bet you are I bet you are man um
but you are your nominee for what like
four Awards right and I know you got
nominated for Latin Grammy I mean what
has this year meant to you a bunch of
beautiful things this year there's been
a lot of learning to a lot of music a
lot of things happenin concentrating
getting focused in my personal life too
that is something that I'm getting used
to do now I have some time to do it so
yeah actually my career is wonderful and
I think it's just the beginning of all
the good things that have about to
happen what's coming is gonna be much
better
[Music]